I'm in the Santa Cruz mountains
in Northern California, and
these are redwood trees.
Redwoods are huge, unbelievably huge.
The ones behind me,
look like they're about 50 meters tall,
it's kind of hard to tell.
But the biggest in the world is
115 meters tall, that's 380 feet.
As i said,
these trees are absolutely enormous.
I want you to remember this scene, and
especially the shape of these trees.
We'll be coming back here later on.
Trees are going to be a recurring theme
throughout your web development career.
In fact, at times it may even feel
like your life revolves around them.
Anyway, I think it's time to
start diving into some code.
I'm going to start by showing
you the basics of HTML.
You'll be writing code at first
inside the Udacity classroom, but
later on in the lesson you'll be using
a text editor specially made for code.
All right, let's get started.